كل الاضواء الحمراء اوضت منذره بالحرب في
السودان لكن لا الامم المتحده ولا القوى
الفاعله راى ذلك بل على العكس تماما نتيجه
رصدتها صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه في
صدمه الدبلوماسيين الغربيين مما الت اليه
الاوضاع في السودان اللافت ان المبعوث
الاممي للسودان فولكر بيرتز رد نافيا على
استفسارات الموظفين الامميين حول وجود
تحذير مبكرا للحرب اول شيء انا بطاقه وفي
لقاء مع العربيه والحدث نهايه الشهر
الماضي كان له راي اخر لم يستبعد فيه
السيناريو الاسوا هل ترى ان الحل اقرب اما
المواجهه اقرب الحل اقرب بكتير المواجهه
طبعا سيناريو ولكن مش ارجح السيناريوهات
انا مازلت متفائلا فيما كان بيرت متفائلا
كانت منذ تصعيد بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريعه تحشيد وتامين للذخيره وتجنيد
وتامين وقود وامدادات حتى الطبيه وفق
الجاردن
داخليا لم تخفى تلك التحركات على الاطراف
فحاكموا اقليم دارفور من اركو منوي حذر في
مارس الماضي من الحرب وحث الطرفين على عدم
القتال في المدن قراءات اخرى يبدو انها
اربكت المشهد فالبعض اطمئن للموقف
الامريكي الذي لم يصدر اي تحذيرات
غير ان المشهد الان معاكس تماما وصادم
والمخاوف تتعاظم من انجرار البلاد الى حرب
اهليه طاحنه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات